nous sommes à l'automne 2001 et tout ce
passe bien dans la vie d'abdullah
almalki sa nouvelle entreprise
d'exportation produits électroniques
fonctionnent très bien
il vient d'emménager dans la région
d'ottawa avec sa femme leurs trois
enfants et ses parents
tout va bien sauf que dès qu'il sort de
chez lui il a l'impression d'être suivi
en masse traitement d'une voiture ont
toujours la même me suivaient elles
disparaissaient revenait d disparaissait
encore comme ce parc à partir de ce
moment je me suis mis à vérifie
régulièrement derrière moi et il est bel
et bien prise en filature par le service
canadien du renseignement de sécurité et
par la grc
c'est le passé d' al malki qui les a mis
sur sa piste
[Musique]
en 1995
fraîchement diplômé de l'université
carleton
al malki part en afghanistan il
travaille pour l'onu et pour une ong
canadienne dirigée par ahmed saïd khadr
ce canadien d'origine égyptienne sera
par la suite identifié par le scrs comme
un proche d'oussama ben laden
son travail à lohan gérant al malki
suspect aux yeux du scrs à son retour au
canada en plus des filatures les agents
lit son courrier et scrute ses appels
téléphoniques ainsi que ces transactions
bancaires
puis surviennent les attaques du 11
septembre
à partir de ce moment la pression sur la
grc et les services de renseignement qui
ré pradic allemand on ignorait s'il y
aurait une troisième quatrième ou
cinquième attaque nous devions rester
alerte richard fadden ex directeur du
scrs est à l'époque conseiller en
sécurité du premier ministre
à ce moment là il fallait savoir ce qui
se passait au canada et aussi chez nos
alliés
qu'est ce qui se passait dans le monde
qui partait à l'étranger qui revenait au
pays
on savait qu'il fallait collaborer
beaucoup plus entre nous et se
transmettre davantage d'informations au
quartier général du scrs à ottawa le
message est lancé
il faut trouver les cellules d'al qaïda
au pays et les soupçons se portent
immédiatement sur abdullah almalki c'est
l'ex agent fingers qui était responsable
du dossier
vous avez des spécialistes du
renseignement stationné loyaux qui font
de leur mieux pour la sécurité du pays
et des citoyens
ils font tout ce qu'ils peuvent qu'est
ce qu'on peut demander de mieux
nos collègues de la sib ici ont obtenu
plus de 18000 documents secrets du scrs
et de la grc
il révèle pour la première fois de
stupéfiants exemples de violations des
droits de la personne et de complicité
lors de cas de torture quelques semaines
après les attaques du 11 septembre des
agents de la grc sont convoqués par le
scrs qui sollicitent leur aide pour
faire avancer les enquêtes de
contre-terrorisme pour l'enseignement
doit être transmis immédiatement aux
autres agences occidentales dans le
compte rendu de cette rencontre on a
qu'abdullah al malki est une cible
prioritaire du scrs depuis deux ans
al-malki a été identifié comme un
possible agents d'approvisionnement de
l'organisation ben laden
le mot clé dans cette phrase est le mot
possible mais le lendemain le mot
possible et retiré de la note de la grc
on écrit quand crois qu al malki est un
agent d'approvisionnement pour ben laden
et al qaïda
la grc envoie aussitôt une alerte à
travers le monde
abdullah almalki est décrit par le scrs
comme un membre important d'al-qaïda
cet avis est aussi transmis à la cia
[Musique]
al malki et maintenant surveillé 24
heures sur 24 mais des agents de la grc
s'étonne de l'image alarmistes de
terroristes que leur propose le scrs il
ne constate rien de suspect un mémo d'un
agent de la grc décrit al malki ainsi le
groupe de travail arrive difficilement à
établir quoi que ce soit sur lui
sinon qu'il s'agit d'un arabe qui se
déplace un peu partout
bien que son comportement n'est rien de
suspect les soupçons s'accumulent
rapidement
en novembre al-malki qui te pays ils
seront en malaisie faire un long séjour
chez sa belle famille sa femme et ses
enfants le rejoignent
en malaisie on le surveille ces appels
sont sous écoute électronique
le scrs apprend qu'il doit visiter sa
grand-mère en syrie la cia on est
aussitôt avisé le 28 mars 2002 un
rapport confidentiel de la grc sur al
malki signal on nous a aussi informé que
cet individu a été mis sur une liste de
surveillance
il sera donc détenu et interrogé la
vidal mal qui est sur le point de
basculer ce qui est central dans la
sphère al malki s'est classé rs a décidé
de transmettre ces soupçons peut
seulement à des pays alliés comme les
états unis mais aussi au régime syrien
de bachar al assad malgré son bilan
épouvantable en matière de droits de la
personne
les agents canadiens venaient donc de
s'associer de près au juste du
renseignement militaire syrien le
transfert direct d'information du canada
vers interpol en syrie est évident
d'après les documents
si le gouvernement canadien et ses
agences refusait de transmettre des
renseignements à des pays qui au moindre
soupçon ont recours à de mauvais
traitements et je ne dénigre pas ce
point de vue on aurait tout simplement
pas de services de renseignement
le 4 mai 2002 abdullah almalki arrive en
syrie
il n'a aucune idée des informations qui
circulent dans le monde à son sujet des
policiers l'attendent et l'amène à la
prise en farr falestine au centre ville
de damas c'est là qu'il rencontre son
premier interrogateurs il m'a dit vous
voulez vous que l'interrogatoire se
passe bien ou mal
cette reconstitution s'est appuyé sur
les récits de témoins oculaires les
rapports de groupes de défense des
droits de la personne et du département
d'état américain
c'est asthme ils demandaient connaissez
vous cette personne j'ai dit 'on est
moins dix quinze minutes plus si vous
voulez et on clarifie tout ça c'est là
que j'ai reçues le premier coup
le coup était très puissant il monte
lema d'imiter en ne frappant et mon
humanité chat et demain mais ça m'a
profondément humilient ensuite tout
s'est passé très vite
ils m'ont dit couche-toi par terre sur
le ventre
et ils se sont mis à frapper la plante
de mes pieds avec un câble électrique
[Applaudissements]
ils m'ont demandé quels étaient mes
liens avec al qaïda je répondais du
mieux que je pouvais mais ça ne donnait
rien rappelons que la grc avait dit
aussi rien qu al malki était un membre
haut placé d'al qaïda il voulait qu'il
avoue être le bras droit d'oussama ben
laden
quand al malki leur art applique tout le
monde savait que le bras droit d'oussama
ben laden était ayman al zaouahri ses
tortionnaires lui ont dit d'avouer qu'il
était le bras gauche de ben laden au
bout de toutes ces heures de torture
j'ai fait de faux aveux
j'ai dit que j'étais son bras gauche
adam fait à cette étape s'il m'avait
demandé si j'étais un canard j'aurais
dit oui bien sûr je serais ce que vous
voulez et le troisième jour de sa
détention
ses tortionnaires l'ont obligé à se
glisser dans un pneu de voiture moyenne
la partie intérieure du pneu poucet
contre ma nuque
j'étais pliée en deux et complètement
immobilisés
la tête mes bras et parties génitales
mon dos tous ces endroits étaient
vulnérables et ils n'ont épargné aucun
[Musique]
voilà plus de quatre mois qu al malki et
détenus en syrie
qu'entend faire le canada son sujet une
réunion est convoquée au ministère des
affaires étrangères à ottawa la grc est
représenté par un officier supérieur
michèle cabana il estime qu'il faut
transmettre des questions aux enquêteurs
syrie'' pour qu'ils y posa al malki
cette note classée secrète précise
l'inspecteur cabana crois qu'il serait
prudent de commencer à préparer des
questions à partir de l'enquète projet à
au canada les responsables syrie'' s'en
servirait pour interroger al malki lors
de son témoignage devant le juge au
cannet michèle cabanas a plus tard admis
qu'il savait que des canadiens étaient
peut-être torturé mais il est allé de
l'avant car la sécurité du pays est un
enjeu certain nous sembler choquant mais
notre devoir de protéger la population
canadienne nous oblige de temps en temps
à travailler avec des pays qui n'ont pas
le même bilan que nous au chapitre de
droits de la personne et des conditions
de détention des prisonniers
l'inspecteur cabana se trompe dans des
cas où il y à torture ces raisons là ne
tiennent plus alex nive dirige amnesty
international canada et de l'arche
le droit international est très clair à
ce sujet il y a des obligations
fondamentales et le canada est tenu de
les respecter
il est inquiétant est choquant que la
grc n'est pas retenu ces règles de base
rien ne justifie d'exposer une personne
à la torture
le ministère des affaires étrangères est
aussi présent à cette rencontre du 10
septembre
six représentants annonce que franco
pilar est là l'ambassadeur du canada en
syrie a offert son aide
le diplomate propose d'aller en personne
remettre aux services de renseignement
syriens les questions qui seront posées
à al malki
il témoignera par la suite qu'il était
au courant d'allégations de torture en
syrie ni que 100 témoins on ne peut
affirmer avec certitude qu'il y a eu
torture
vous étiez une rencontre au ministère
des affaires étrangères dont le procès
verbal précise que les questions serait
envoyé en syrie malgré le risque de
torture en fait l'ambassadeur pilar et
là les a même transmises en personne aux
services de renseignement qui
torturaient al malki
je trouve qu'il serait un peu facile
pour vous et moi de lire ce procès
verbal après coup je me risquerai plus
tôt a suggéré que ce jour là les
participants ont agi en toute bonne foi
et qu'ils ont cru qu'il fallait le faire
pour mieux protéger notre pays
pendant ce temps les mois passent
il y êtes rogatoire syrien torture
abdullah almalki il le suspende par les
poignets au barreau d'une fenêtre il
fouette ces tortures chabat ce jour là
il me fous étaient avec une ceinture pas
avec des cars électriques
si mes réponses tardent à venir ou si
elle ne leur plaisait pas il me faut
être plus fort jusqu'à ce que ma réponse
leur plaisent ou qu'elle soit assez
rapide mais après un certain temps
non me importe la force des coups de
fois que je recevais
je n'arrivais plus à remuer les lèvres
alors ils m'ont détachées je suis tombé
au sol et j'avais vraiment très mal aux
mains c'était comme si des milliers
d'aiguilhe il y avait été planté en fait
la douleur était devenu tellement
extrême que j'en suis venu à souhaiter
qu'on me coupe tout simplement limite
c'était insupportable
[Musique]
à ottawa le 21 novembre 2002 le scrs et
la grc veulent maintenant participer aux
interrogatoires d'abdullah almalki en
syrie une note envoyée au commissaire de
la grc giuliano à cardelli annonce selon
nos dernières informations les autorités
syriennes serait ouverte à ce que des
membres du scrs supervise les
interrogatoires belle melki le scrs
suggère aux autorités syriennes que la
grc assiste elle aussi à ces
interrogatoires
deux jours plus tard une délégation du
scrs arrive à damas
on ne permettra pas à ses membres
d'assister aux interrogatoires
mais les questions de la délégation ont
été remises aux tortionnaires l one jour
j'ai vu que pour me poser ses questions
il utilisait un document dont le titre
était rencontre avec la délégation
canadienne les 23 et 24 novembre
ils n'ont même pas cherché à cacher que
les questions qu'il posait et les
informations qu'ils recevaient venait du
canada et même qu'il rencontrait des
responsables canadiens
dans la foulée du 11-septembre le scrs
scrutent chaque canadien qui durant les
années 90 a visité les pays en lien avec
le terrorisme comme l'afghanistan
abdullah almalki et le premier suspecte
mais le scrs cherche aussi des personnes
qui connaissent al malki et qui se sont
rendus aussi en afghanistan les soupçons
se portent sur le canado égyptien ahmad
el maati au début des années 90 après
des études à l'université concordia
il a combattu le régime prosoviétique en
afghanistan selon lui il n'était que
chauffeur d'ambulance et cuisiniers de
retour au canada
il téléphone à abdullah almalki en
janvier 2001 le scrs informe la cia qu
el maati à communiquer avec plusieurs
islamistes extrémistes de sa région dont
abdullah almalki selon l'ex agent du
scrs firesky c'est la façon de faire
habituelle
quand on enquête en cible parfois en n1
puis on voit que d'autres personnes
gravitent autour de lui et parfois parmi
ses contacts
certains deviennent plus intéressants
que l'individu ciblés au départ on se
met donc à chercher signe de ces
nouvelles personnes pourraient être
impliquées
elle maxi et camionneurs et son nom est
inscrit sur une liste de surveillance
américaine le 16 août 2000 alors qu'ils
entrent aux états unis il est intercepté
par des douaniers américains après une
fouille il trouve une carte suspecte
dans la cabine il s'agit d'une carte
sont indiqués l'édifice d'énergie
atomique du canada une mine d'uranium de
l'entreprise eldorado et des
laboratoires de contrôle des maladies et
d'études des virus tout cela laisse
croire qu el maati va attaquer des
installations nucléaires ou
biotechnologiques les autorités
américaines informe le scrs et la grc le
renseignement et les informations qui
circulaient sur ces individus laisser
croire qu'ils représentaient une menace
pour le pays
ils n'ont pas été choisies au hasard et
remis entre les mains de la grc
avec toutes les conséquences que cela
allait entraîner mais en fait la carte
compromettantes n'y pas s'ils suspectent
que cela c'était une carte photocopier
très banal qu'on remet souvent ou
livreur et aux camionneurs pour les
aider à trouver leur destination à
travers tous les édifices la situation
n'avait rien de louche c'est une carte
normale et il n'y a rien d'exceptionnel
à ce qu'elle se retrouve dans une cabine
de camion
pourtant le 28 septembre 2001
l'ambassade des états unis envoient une
lettre au commissaire de la grc du llano
hakkar délit à propos d' ahmad el maati
la lettre contient la fameuse carte des
copies de son passeport et ses cartes
d'identité ainsi que des photos et des
billets d'avion de ses déplacements
entre le canada et la syrie les
américains demandent qu el maati soient
arrêtés et détenus
la grc réaliste qui lui manque de
preuves mais et leurs plans en novembre
2001 el maati et suivi à l'aéroport il
prend un vol vers la syrie où ils seront
pour son mariage
la grc en avise les américains sachant
qu'il sera arrêté à son arrivée
el maati atterri à damas le lendemain il
est aussitôt conduit à la prison de
phares falestine où il sera interrogé
par le renseignement militaire syrien et
au plus tôt en fait ils m'ont emmené
dans un bureau probablement d'un
officier supérieur
ils m'ont mis un sac sur la tête et
m'ont menotté les bras derrière
et instruments là m'a parlé en arabe ima
tirs raconte moi tout je lui ai demandé
comment ça tout qu'est ce que vous
voulez savoir
il a répondu je vais t'apprendre barre
ils se sont aussitôt mis à me frapper le
visage en disant que c'est comme ça
qu'ils allaient m'approche et se sont
mis à me poser toutes sortes de
questions sur ma vie au canada ce genre
de questions nous pouvait provenir que
de gens au canada le 15 novembre 2001 à
ottawa la grc s'inquiète elle ne veut
surtout pas que son application dans ce
qu'on fait subir à ahmad el maati soit
découverte par qui que ce soit y compris
par des responsables au consulat
canadien à damas li courriels internes
montrent que la grc savait très bien ce
qu el maati allait subir il sera arrêté
et interrogé à la syrienne et au sous
sol de sa prison à damas el maati
apprend comme on interroge à la syrienne
ils ont attaché mes jambes à mes mains
par en arrière
ils montrent immobilisé je me sentais
comme un animal qu'on va tuer au sol je
ne pouvais plus bouger
ils ont commencé en torture histoire ils
m'ont souhaité de toute leur force
partout sur le corps la douleur des cris
c'était vrai
incroyable ce thème la fille si cette
approche et il m'a dit tu vas voir ce
que je vais te faire il s'est mis à
brûler le menton et la jambe puis s'est
mis à hurler
alors il m'a dit maintenant je vais te
brûler les yeux je me suis mis à crier
sinon je vous en supplie je ferai tout
ce que vous demanderez vraiment tout ce
que vous voudrez j'écrirai tout ce que
vous ne verrez plus tôt il avoue donc
que les membres d'une cellule d'al qaïda
au canada puis on veut qu'il avoue un
projet d'attentât contre l'ambassade des
états unis à ottawa
mais el maati klein d'être envoyé à
guantanamo ce raccordement nous alors
jean-louis répondu non non ce n'est pas
à l'ambassade des états unis mais
parlement du canada ça m'a beaucoup
surpris il m'a regardé il m'a dit oui
c'est bien plus fort ça c'est vraiment
meilleure possible alors vous inventer
tous pour éviter d'être envoyé aux états
unis pour que j'arrête d'un torturer les
aveux dès le match s'ils sont aussitôt
envoyé au quartier général de la grc à
ottawa en commission denquête michel
cabanas a dit qu'il savait qu'on avait
peut-être soutirer des aveux sous la
torture
mais en ajoutant à mon avis peu importe
les circonstances de l'interrogatoire
les aveux qu'il a fournis demeure valide
le 2 janvier 2002 après sept semaines de
détention dans une prison syrienne
el maati est envoyé non pas au canada
mais au caire
l'egypte accueille alors des prisonniers
du monde entier qui sont transférés par
les états unis
ils sont torturés sous la supervision de
la cia
el maati y est restée détenue 10 mois
menotté dans une étroite cellule
infestés d'insectes et de ras beyrouth
bingo il m'apportait du riche en un
morceau de pain j'étais détenue en
isolement
avec comme pourrait l'être un simple
trou à même le sol des rats sortait il y
avait d'énormes coquerel les voyait
mange ma nourriture je devais partager
mon repas avec les rats et les
coquerelles
les documents secrets que nous avons en
main démontre que le ministère des
affaires étrangères du canada savait que
des canadiens étaient torturés à
l'étranger en ou 2002 des responsables
de l'ambassade canadienne rencontre
ahmad el maati à la prison de tora au
caire
il note que la condition physique et le
moral du sujet nous ont semblé bon il
était calme et s'exprimer de façon
rationnelle le sujet nous informer qu'au
cours des deux mois de sa détention
syrie on l'a battu aux pieds aux jambes
torturé décharge électrique efforcé de
donner de fausses informations
certains responsables au ministère des
affaires étrangères s'inquiète des
tortures subies par des canadiens
détenus à l'étranger mais le scrs et la
grc craignent qu el maati ne soit libéré
par les égyptiens et aurait fait part de
ses craintes aux autorités égyptiennes
ont nous 2002 cette note de la grc
précise avoir reçu l'assurance des
autorités égyptiennes qu el maati ne
sera pas libéré de sitôt
le scrs a été invité à se joindre à la
préparation des questions qui lui seront
posées à la grc l'inspecteur michel
cabana souhaite aussi que ces agents
participent aux interrogatoires en
egypte
l'inspecteur cabana explique que la
préparation de l'entretien prévu avec el
maati en egypte était commencée
les représentants du consulat canadien
en egypte demande à el maati de
rencontrer des policiers canadiens la
prison il refuse et dit qu'il ne parlera
aux policiers canadiens quand territoire
canadien
il va bientôt le regretter
il entend mener tout droit à la salle
d'interrogatoire ou de torture en fait
ils m'ont électrocuté
il me donnait des décharges électriques
partout sur le corps
il disait pourquoi tu as refusé la
demande de l'ambassade pour rencontrer
les gens des services de sécurité
canadiens prochaine fois dealers ou
ambassades canadiennes venait de
s'impliquer directement dans la torture
que je subissais l'ex agent du
renseignement au scrs fingers qui
regrettent certaines décisions prises
dans le dossier el maati even after même
après qu'elles mathy est dit au
ministère des affaires étrangères qu on
le torture en syrie et que leur s et rs
et la grc le savez sans continuer le
partage d'informations l'envoi des
questions c'était toujours correct non
ce n'est pas quoi selon moi dès qu'on a
la certitude ou d'épreuves partiel qu'un
canadien subi de mauvais traitements on
devrait cesser toute coopération à ce
moment-là tout à fait
le 31 mai 2002 une délégation de
policiers canadiens seront quartier
général du fbi à washington le chef des
enquêtes antiterroristes michel cabana
de la grc
il fait une présentation suggérant une
réponse globale dans la lutte au
terrorisme
il nomme deux suspects canadien abdullah
almalki et ahmad el maati qui ont déjà
été torturés à l'étranger
la grc ajoute un troisième nom à sa
liste de suspects
maher arar une décision qu'elle
regrettera pour maher arar
tout commence peu après le 11 septembre
des agents du scrs l'observent dans un
café d'ottawa en compagnie d'abdullah
almalki quatre mois après la
présentation de cabanas pour le fbi à
harar est arrêtée lors d'une escale à
l'aéroport jfk de new york
il se retrouve quelques jours plus tard
en syrie dans la même prison où sont
torturés les autres canadiens les
documents obtenus par 6 bis si radio
canada démontrent qu'on connaissait très
bien leur cas à ottawa
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le 21 novembre 2002 le commissaire de la
grc giuliano à cardelli reçoit cette
note d'informations secrètes les
autorités syriennes nous ont avisés car
have a avoué être impliqué dans le
recrutement canada de candidats pour
l'organisation al qaïda cet aveu brosse
un portrait clair des liens de maher
arar en tant que recruteur avec abdullah
almalki et ahmad el maati des
informations mensongères obtenus par la
torture
[Applaudissements]
c'est à l'été 2003 que les médias
parlent enfin de ces canadiens détenus
et torturés à l'étranger
la femme de maher arar milite
publiquement pour obtenir sa libération
et exige de l'action de la part du
gouvernement mais nous sommes à l'été
2003 et la pression est très forte sur
le gouvernement pour qu'il fasse libérer
les trois canadiens torturés à
l'étranger
mais pendant ce temps le scrs et la grc
veulent pousser un autre canadien vers
la salle de tortures pendant qu'elle est
encore accessible
moyenne nourdine était le directeur
d'une école islamique à toronto
il s'est rendu plusieurs fois dans le
nord de l'irak pour y voir sa famille
dans ce document du scrs on lit qu'ils
étaient soupçonnés d'avoir acheminé de
l'argent entre toronto et l'irak en 2002
l'année suivante le scrs affirme le rôle
joué par noureddine dans le mouvement
extrémiste islamique est confirmée par
sa récente participation ou transfert
d'argent à un groupe terroriste dans le
nord de l'irak
nourdine dément tout lien avec quelques
organisations terroristes que ce soit en
avant je me suis rendu trois fois en
irak
comment peut-on être un messager et
faire juste trois voyages en avion
transportant si peu d'argent
une grosse organisation n'aurait pas pu
survivre avec l'argent que j'avais pour
vous cette absurde ans
absurde l'argent était pour ma famille
nourdine a toujours déclaré aux douanes
canadiennes lee montant qu'il
transportait par exemple ici 4000 euros
et 12 mille dollars américains
dez non il n'existe pas de façon
d'envoyer de l'argent à nos familles
là bas on doit y aller apporter l'argent
nous mêmes
à toronto le 16 octobre 2003 nourdine
part pour amsterdam
eelv en irak à partir de l'europe et va
revenir au canada à partir de la syrie
la grc informe aussitôt la cia
washington que les services de
surveillance confirme que nourdine est à
bord d'un vol de klm au terminal 3 et
qu'ils voyagent seuls le scrs avise les
services de renseignement étrangers
nous confirmons être à la recherche du
citoyen canadien moyenne noureddine et
nous prendrons les mesures en vue de sa
détention
merci de votre collaboration si vous
voyez l'individu
comme dans les trois autres cas le scrs
s'empresse de fournir à la syrie et aux
états unis
la liste des questions en vue de
l'interrogatoire de nourdine à son
arrivée en syrie en janvier 2004 en
transit pour le canada nordine est
arrêté et un garde frontière le conduit
dans une pièce à l'arrière de l'édifice
[Musique]
il m'a dit vous êtes recherché
qu'est ce que ça voulait dire pour vous
quand il m'a dit vous êtes recherché
ça m'a rappelé la dictature que j'ai
connu en irak
vous pouvez détenir des gens sans donner
aucune raison ensuite un lieutenant est
entré et m'a dit tu ne verras plus
jamais la lumière du soleil puis il y
conduit à la même prison de damas que
les trois autres canadiens
il y est torturé par les mêmes agents du
renseignement militaire syrien mon fils
c'était comme si on mettait du feu sur
une brûlure il avait son bras il me fous
étaient les pieds de toutes ses forces
pour nourdine il ne fait aucun doute que
les questions qu'on lui pose vient du
scrs et de la grc irish actes ça m'a
bouleversé mon pays supposés s'occuper
de ma sécurité
ces massifs qui comment pouvait-il
envoyé ces questions et me laisser à
leur mercie dans la salle des tortures
c'était la cellule 3 c'était écrit sur
la porte comme ceux ci c'est le nombre 3
en arabe et il m'appelait 3 il m'avait
retiré mon nom durant toute ma détention
je portais le nom de ma cellule la
détention d'abdullah almalki en syrie
s'est poursuivie durant 22 mois amnistie
internationale a construit une réplique
précise de sa cellule
je ne sais pas comment ils ont construit
cet édifice mais de ma cellule je
pouvais entendre tout ce qui se passait
à l'étagé des interrogatoires tous les
cris les tortures j'entendais tout et
c'était insupportable
alors j'ai décidé d'inverser mes
horaires je suis parvenu à dormir durant
la journée je me réveillais la nuit
comme ça je n'entendais pas l'écrit
énormément ce qui m'arrivait j'exclus
est de mes pensées tout ce qui se
passait hors de ma cellule je m'empêcher
de penser à ma femme à mes enfants à mes
parents du couple huriez tous les jours
mais on ne le permettait pas entre nous
la règle était de ne montrer aucun signe
de faiblesse devant les autres détenus
on savait que tout le monde pleurait
qu'on avait tous des moments de
vulnérabilité mais on avait besoin de
rester discret en octobre 2003 maher
arar libéré par le régime syrien y
rentrer au canada lors d'une conférence
de presse
il annonce que lui et d'autres détenus
ont été torturés
notre gouvernement doit faire tout en
son pouvoir pour garantir la sécurité
des canadiens détenus en syrie et les
aider à rentrer au pays
en janvier 2004 ça fait plus de deux ans
que des canadiens innocents croupissent
en prison à l'étranger avec la
complicité du scrs et la grc l'ambassade
canadienne à damas fait enfin pression
pour que le régime syrien les libère je
tiens à remercier le gouvernement
canadien
le 13 janvier le directeur d'école
moyenne noureddine libéré et rentrer au
canada deux jours plus tard même fin
pour le camionneur ahmad el maati
libérés des prisons égyptiennes au début
de 2004 sa mère est venue au caire
il fera par la porte à la ouverte et
elle s'est évanouie par terre elle m'a
dit par après que c'était un des plus
beaux jours de sa vie le 10 mars 2004
l'homme d'affaires abdullah almalki et
toucy libéré en syrie les membres de sa
famille sont choqués en constatant son
état d oujda certains est a bouleversé
quand ils me voyaient j'étais vraiment
très maigre
en fait je pouvais compter mes côtes et
maison
en 2004 à ottawa on réalise de plus en
plus que les forces policières et les
services de sécurité ont dépassé les
limites en donnant aux états unis et à
d'autres états des renseignements menant
à la torture de suspect et pourtant en
2010 le gouvernement harper émettre une
directive qui permet au scrs d'utiliser
l'effet obtenues grâce à la torture s'il
ya menace urgente contre lévis où la
propriété au pays
disons que je reçois une information
comme directeur du scrs suggérant de
façon crédible que des vies sont
menacées qu'on a tout fait pour le
vérifier et qu'il est possible que cette
information était obtenue sous la
torture je diffuserai ce renseignement
s'il pouvait sauver des vies au pays
la personne dirait qu'en payant demande
pour des faits obtenus sous la torture
les tortionnaires vont continuer à
torturer cela pourrait être vrai en
partie mais je les inviterai assumer mon
rôle quand je dirigeais le scrs par
exemple les dix ans qu'on fait face à
une banque qui est prête à exploser à
québec ou ailleurs au pays
mais qu'on refuserait d'agir parce que
cette information a peut-être été
obtenus sous la torture selon le
ministère de la sécurité publique sous
le gouvernement trudeau
cette directive ministérielle traitant
des faits div il dit sous la torture est
toujours en vigueur
les décideurs dans ce dossier on subit
bien peu de contre court après qu'il ait
fourni de faux renseignements dans le
cas maher arar devant du comité
parlementaire
on a poussé vers la sortie le patron de
la grc du llano à cardelli il a été
nommé un poste de haut responsable à
interpol après son implication dans le
cas de rupture d'allemagne fille
l'ambassadeur canadien en syrie franco
pilar et là a poursuivi sa carrière de
diplomate et vit aujourd'hui une
confortable retraite à monte carlo et
après avoir dirigé les actions de la grc
dans ce dossier l'inspecteur michel
cabanas a été promu sous commissaire de
la grc poste qu'il occupe toujours
il a refusé d'être interviewé pour ce
reportage
le dossier étant toujours devant les
tribunaux plusieurs policiers croient
encore que les suspects canadiens
étaient coupables et qu'ils ont en
partie causé leur propre malheur
je ne vous dis pas que ce dossier a été
mené de la bonne façon
car ce n'est pas le cas on ne peut pas
non plus simplifié et dire que le
gouvernement était dans le tort pour
tout ce qu'il a fait ils ont mal agi eux
aussi deux commissions d'enquêté
fédérale ont blanchi les canadiens
torturés et affirmé que le gouvernement
canadien était responsable de leur
mauvais traitements à l'étranger
en 2007 maher arar a reçu une
indemnisation de 10 millions 400 mille
dollars et des excuses officielles de la
part du premier ministre du canada
les commissions dans lequel on établit
une responsabilité bien plus directe du
gouvernement dans la torture d' al malki
nourdine et el maati pourtant depuis dix
ans il mène une bataille en cours pour
obtenir réparation
ah oui je crois que j'ai été maltraité
par mon gouvernement comme lui il m'a
trahi et trahi ma confiance
il ne m'a pas porté secours quand
j'étais en danger d'écraser c'est eux
qui ont causé mais torture c'est eux qui
ont fait que j'ai été détenu ils ont
fait perdre énormément d'argent à mon
entreprise et mes frères ont vu leurs
vies détruites
la vie de mes enfants est détruite et le
gouvernement n'a strictement rien fait
il n'a rien fait pour changer les choses
ou pour nous rendre justice - réputation
a été salie des gens nous évite de peur
de devenir coupables par association
en fait on vit comme dans les limbes
c'est comme si j'étais ni sur le sol ni
au fond de la tombe
à ce jour le gouvernement du canada n'a
offert aucune excuse officielle ni
aucune compensation trois hommes